hi guys and welcome to this week's
episode as always we are partnered with
QT which enables you to have better
fuller and more interesting
conversations without all the nonsense
and the bim fire and all the hate
spilled that you get in the comment
section of YouTube and Facebook and
Twitter and all the rest of it as always
if you want to access the conversation
click on the pinned link below and it
will take you direct to the conversation
and we will also be online answering
your questions responding to them on
that comment section so if you want to
get involved in the discussion click on
the link underneath in this week's
wonderful episode we are interviewing
the wonderful youtuber cosmic skeptic
and he's talking about atheism and
veganism two subjects that are gonna
trigger a lot of people if you want to
talk about either of those two subjects
but primarily veganism we're gonna be
talking about that in the Q T do you
agree with it do you not do you think
it's a diet that's going to save the
world or do you think it's just for
self-involved their news no lefties they
want to ball the arse off everybody
around them make your voice heard click
on the link below and get involved in
the Q T next week we've got our
wonderful guest who is the economist
William Halligan who is talking all
about the housing crisis now if you've
got some particular questions go onto
the Qt and we can have a big discussion
about it and you can get your voice
heard
but Constantine and I will be on there
and we'll be answering your questions
and you'll be able to get involved
without all the nonsense of the bile and
the rubbish of social media enjoy the
episode
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm opossums and kissing
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we asked the experts our
Berlin guest this week is a youtuber
called cosmic skeptic
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me it's going well so far for
anyone who doesn't know you just tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life a lot of questions um my
name is Alex as a I'm a youtuber which
is a strange term to apply to myself but
I suppose it's the only one that fits
I've been in for about 3 years
previously I was talking about atheism
online was the main thing that I would
do trying to contradict religious claims
that people were making beginning is a
kind of tongue-in-cheek edgy atheist
type thing and then you realize that you
start getting emails from from people
all around the world saying you know I'm
trapped in my country and my parents
will kill me if they found out about my
religion what should my lack of religion
what should I do
anything ah maybe I should start taking
this a little more seriously and so he
started talking more about philosophy
and the politics of religion and then I
took a complete 180 in the past year or
so and started just completely talking
about almost nothing other than animal
rights all of a sudden so that's the
most recent kind of a path that I've
taken
but I'm essentially you're somebody who
says things on the internet I mean you
say you ask the experts I don't know I
mean that's very charitable term I don't
know that I'd be able to apply that to
myself in any in any respect but people
seem to have enjoyed what I've had to
say so far so that's about all I've got
going I love how British that is don't
play in any level of expertise that you
have and actually when you said you did
a complete 180 I thought you're gonna go
on devout Muslim now so that was a good
joke finally why not go I do consider it
sometimes I think about the just the the
level of ad revenue that I'd receive I
made some video about why I would
convert it to radical Islam or something
made that biddy monetize that no revenue
for you no but let's talk about religion
because one of the things that we've
talked to quite a few people about and I
know that you've debated Douglas Murray
in the past on certain issues one of the
things that neither of us are believers
in in that traditional way but one of
the things that we've talked to a lot of
people about is the impact of a lack of
religion on society and it feels like
we're living in increasingly
individualized times and a lot of people
have linked that to the death of God if
you like then everyone essentially I
think Lauren's Fox when he was on our
show said that he feels a little bit
like it will become a religion of one so
do you have any thoughts on you know
religion may not be true but it's a glue
that binds society together yeah well
look I mean it's clear to me that the
only reason why it's certainly true that
the people who lose their religion are
left with a kind of feeling of emptiness
a lot of the time that's why that's the
case one thing that people try to do is
just ignore that that's the case or deny
that it happens of course it does happen
you know but the reason it does is
because these people are told from from
birth that the thing that gives their
life meaning is their devotion to God
that they are nothing without the
complete and utter subjugation to the
Creator that they were they were made to
appease and they're told that if that
goes away there would be nothing for you
if if Christ has not been raised your
faith is futile you're still in your
sins it's a miserable existence and so
when that faith is taken away or not
taken away but but fools away from them
and they realize that there's just no
grounding for it of course they're going
to feel like there's no purpose for life
because they've been told and
conditioned for all of their life that
that's where it comes from right so the
whole problem with this and the reason
why I think that people in society are
beginning to feel like they have a lack
of purpose is because of the fact that
we act as though it's the only place it
can come from we don't teach children
the the meaning and purpose and
fulfillment that can come from
connection with with other human beings
without needing some kind of divine
buttress for it you don't need it to be
predicated you don't need the love that
you have
for your friends and for your family to
be a derivative of the love that the
creator has for you it can just be a
love that you have for yourself and that
almost makes it all the more special and
meaningful if you really think that this
life is just a precursor to an eternity
by the very nature of something being
infinite it means that this life that
we're living is totally meaningless what
does it matter if we're suffering if
we're dying what does it matter if you
pass someone on the street who's
freezing to death because they've got an
eternity of bliss waiting out of them
provided they're a Christian of course
but this this kind of thinking
completely completely soaks meaning out
of life the life that we have now and so
I think it's almost quite ironic when
people turn around and say but you know
if we take away God from society
there'll be no meaning to live now it's
like we have every meaning to live the
moment when we take that away because we
realized that this is all we've got it
will make the most of it it's very
interesting that you say that and
especially you know that this is all
we've got because it's is when you
finally accept that that in reality you
start living because you realize that
life is precious and finite and that
every moment you have could be your loss
and you need to make the most of it
absolutely it's like you know I don't
know if somebody told you that you were
going to die next year you've got some
kind of illness or something how would
that change your life I mean there be a
lot of people I told to [ __ ] off
whatever the case it would change your
life in a great many ways you would
start having a lot more enthusiasm to
complete the tasks that you want to
complete right if you told you had a
serval diagnosis but here's the thing
right if let's say that diagnosis was
six months that would totally change
your life let's say it was one year it
still probably be pretty pretty
effective well have you had any two
years to live and it's like well yeah
and but what you realize is that we are
in a state of terminal decline we are
going to die right the further away you
move maybe the the less urgency there is
in your action but if you stretch that
on to infinity then there's no reason to
do what you're doing today it's like
having an infinite pool of money and
being given a dollar but
is having a hundred dollars in your bank
account and being given $10 so it's like
it's life changing with the one day that
we have today to get the things done we
want to do becomes far more urgent when
you recognize that there's a there's a
limit to your day so now that's kind of
in an exaggerated form you see it very
clearly with people who are diagnosed
with terminal illnesses who had like a
bucket list but we're all on that
diagnosis right now it's just that our
diagnosis is maybe seventy years or so
so of course we should be applying the
same logic we should say that it's the
shortening of that life that should give
us the very meaning to get out of bed
and do the things we want to do because
we're not going to have a chance to do
the matter we've perished and it's very
interesting as well that I did what do
you think about the counter-argument to
that that especially religion means that
you were part of a group where tribal
animals being part of a group means that
we feel more connected we feel happier
we feel safer yeah well I mean if it's
if it's false hope and false safety then
a true friend wouldn't allow another
friend to be part of that community with
them right like it's not like we can't
build communities on secular foundation
that's right it's not like that can't be
done the King give us some examples I
mean talking talking broadly like the
the camaraderie that you can have with
just a friendship group is is far more
meaningful than the camaraderie that the
average person I would say who's maybe
an Anglican has with the members of
their church on a Sunday when they go
along I mean you know I used to be a
Catholic and I remember I used to go to
church and like yeah it was quite nice
you show up and there's some people
there and if you kind of elderly lady
sat singing the hymns and stuff it's not
like that was the the basis of my social
function you know you there are so many
other ways in which we can connect with
with other human beings if you play a
musical instrument you can join a band
or get in a hit in an orchestra you
could you can join a choir you can go to
a comedy club you know you can do
whatever it is you want to do and it has
precisely the same effect but without
the spiritual baggage you're told no do
you know what you can come in and sit
with us and have a nice time and we can
do things together and we can become
friends and share these experiences but
I'm not going to be continually
reminding you while we're doing so that
you're destined to hell if you don't
kiss the feet of a god that's the
difference you know I'm not requiring
anything off you I'm not
saying that yes you get my love but you
also have to have this fear I'm saying
no let's get together let's love each
other it's have a good time and don't
worry about the extra baggage that isn't
necessary for the thing that's being
used to justify the existence of the
institution see it's interesting because
I'm kind of somewhere towards you but
also maybe not quite there before the
reason that Francis was talking about
like if there was a religion that didn't
require me to believe in God I think I'd
probably sign up yeah so what about
Buddhism it sound nice here well yeah it
does I mean just kind of feels weird it
just it's just wrong as foreign isn't it
I think yeah I think people again they
say things like well what about a
religion where you know you don't need
to believe in a God what about a
religion where you don't actually need
to meet up and have religious observance
well and it seems like what we're saying
is like the further away you get from
what would traditionally be called a
religion the better it gets
yeah that's what I'm saying in so many
words the further away you get from
religion the better your religion is of
course but what does that say about the
concept of religion as a whole I mean
how are we defining religion here it's a
very difficult thing to define most
people most scholars will go for a kind
of family resemblance model that's not
like a list where every religion has all
of them and if it doesn't have one of
them it's not a religion so you'll have
things like belief in God moral code you
know community ethos and you don't need
all of them but they kind of as long as
there's enough of them there but like
what we're beginning to do is kind of
pluck these away until we're just left
with these singular characteristics like
community ethos and we're saying I guess
we could technically call that a
religion so you're welcome to that if
you want but I really don't think that's
what people mean when they when they
lament that the removal of religion from
society I mean what if we replaced the
state religion with that kind of pseudo
spirituali spirituality that kind of
like vague notion of like something
other like we wouldn't be a religious
state at all we'd just be a state who
has a strange metaphysical thing that at
some times references when it talks
about community ethos right we're
talking about religion let's talk about
religion if we're not talking about
religion and let's not label it religion
just to keep ourselves kind of sad
now I hear what you're saying I guess
what I'm saying is I mean one of the
fundamental transformations in human
history was when we went from the kind
of pagan religions which where the the
temple it was the house of God we're
actually ordinary people weren't allowed
inside it was just serviced by the
priests to being the church being the
house of the people where people would
come together right I mean look at
what's happening now in our society
people have made politics or religion
and have split along a kind of faith
let's say not maybe a religion but
people have become very religious about
their politics and it feels like to me
maybe you don't agree I don't know I
mean I agree but can you name a time in
history when that hasn't been the case I
know I think it depends I think it
depends my point is that I feel like
increasingly there's nothing that binds
society together beyond those divisions
so for example in the country which was
strongly Christian let's say people
might be left or right or conservative
or labour but there would be a set of
commonly held customs or values that
they would all share that at the end of
the day they would say well yes we are
all British aware or Christian or
whatever it might have been now I feel
like the fractures are becoming so much
stronger and so much bigger because
there is not a glue that binds us
together and I hear you that you know
that there's a lot of superstition and
irrationality when it comes to religion
I just wonder whether the social impact
of having these you might call them
delusions you know Richard Dawkins might
call it a delusion which he does I
wonder whether some some delusions have
utility I mean look at you well no
Harare and his book sapiens where he
talks about the fact that the reason
that we as human beings as homo sapiens
have been able to achieve what we've
been able to achieve is our ability to
have myths that bind us together beyond
that tribal small group yeah we're I'm
drunk there are most of things to say
the first is that to say that something
has been useful as a useful as a means
to produce evolutionary results doesn't
mean that we should continue to use it
to base our societies upon I mean like
rape was also an evolutionarily useful
tool but we're not going to say that
because of that
we should still be doing it we can
recognize that that was probably
necessary in the evolution of our
species and if it weren't for that we
wouldn't be here but it's another thing
entirely to say that that we should
because of that we should base our and
pace our social institutions on it and
there goes the monetization somebody's
going to clip that Alex and it's not the
cosmic skeptic says rape is necessary
there are far worse things that I could
say when we get on to veganism
I think that what were we talking about
we're talking about the religion being
unnecessary
perhaps delusion too by talking about
you know we're talking about the balance
between our value of truth and our value
of comfort let's say also I'd be careful
to note that that your point is valid in
saying that politics is is so divisive
that maybe we need something
transcendental that people can refer to
an agree upon their what do you want it
to be and what do you want to happen
when people don't agree with it
the reason religion has been so
successful as a social as a as a
producing social coherence in the past
is because anybody who deviated from it
has been marginalized or killed
right of course it's going to produce a
coherent society of everybody who
doesn't comply is kind of gotten rid of
right what are you gonna do with the
dissenters yeah the whole point they
when I'm Russian oh I know what we're
gonna do the whole point of the the the
individualist revolution the
Enlightenment that the realization that
then maybe we should start treating
people as though they have value of
their own accord and not just in the
utility that they serve to greater
society is to say that actually no there
is value in a difference of opinion and
if that means that we have to give up
these cherished institutions of religion
which ostensibly have caused social
cohesion and progression but when we
really analyze it who actually cause a
lot of disruption have actually caused
the opposite right but for every example
you can give and religion producing a
well-oiled functioning society I can
give you an example of where it's
completely destroyed one right it does
both and it's
it's one of those trade-offs that we
have to make right and to me I think
that firstly most people wouldn't be
comfortable with the idea of admitting
something as false but saying that we're
going to just accept it and use it as
though it's it's true anyway I mean I've
got no problem with people accepting
religious ideas recognizing that they're
false but kind of embracing the ethos
and and and living by those those
principles anyway I think that's what
someone like Jordan Peterson does I
don't think he actually believes in the
metaphysical claims of Jesus's
resurrection but he's he's a great
mythical meaning in it it's fine you
know again he's welcome to that I don't
mind that at all but my point is this
there are people on this planet who
believe that the earth is ten thousand
years old right they are wrong they are
incorrect aprove ibly so there are
people who don't believe that we're
evolved creatures and what effect does
that have on the rest of so I mean you
might say that if you accept that we're
evolved creatures then you know our our
special place as humans is gotten rid of
our meaning is taken away and this is
what people said when the Origin of
Species was first published but the
opposite is also true if you if you
restrict people from learning about
evolution like people are trying to do
in the United States for instance then
you're restricting the opportunity of
realizing their place in the animal
kingdom their place in nature and the
respect that they should have for nature
because of that fact right it goes both
ways with what I'm saying but as a as a
philosopher I'm interested in what I
think is true and the arguments that I
think have have rational grounding for
them and so yeah I don't know if
somebody came along to you and in any
other field other than religion and said
to you listen I've got this thing that I
believe and you say well here's what I
think it's not true and you go yeah you
know what you're actually right I mean I
don't think it is true but yeah I just
kind of just kind of like it well it's
interesting that you make that point
that was sorry fine so let me just
finish this bit with Alex I actually
you've already made me question some of
what I said in terms of the idea like
when you said what do we want that thing
to be that binds us together that's a
very interesting question and I think a
very important one yeah I guess the
issue is that everything is so
politicized that even what we the three
of us would certainly I imagine agree in
this room you know the Enlightenment
values of freedom of Express
freedom of scientific research all of
this kind of stuff that's divisive now
you know being Pro free speech makes you
right-wing now all this kind of thing so
it's just a question I guess is can we
come to a common set of values but again
look at national identity you know
saying we're British that's now toxic
you know it's I think we're I guess the
society where we are now and maybe why
people say that the death of God has
caused this is that we are unable at the
moment to come together around the
common set of values no matter how big
or abstract they are just because
everything has become so divided but let
me put a counterpoint to your final
point which is about the utility of
false beliefs one of the things that I'd
say to you as a comedian for example is
it's incredibly useful as a comedian to
believe that you are incredibly funny
even if you are repeatedly proven wrong
by an audience it was one gig but what
anyone will tell you that confidence is
a is a huge thing in almost any career
in any profession the belief that you
are able to do something helps you do
that thing better yeah even if maybe you
you're not you know you're not actually
that good at that thing yes I mean that
the difference is firstly like you
recognize that it's being used as a tool
right it's what um I think Brett
Weinstein has called these metaphorical
truths for example the gun is always
loaded right yeah thing to believe even
though you know it's not like you should
treat it as though it is but but you're
not making this metaphysical claim
you're not actually necessarily
believing this thing it's like if you're
on stage and people say you know imagine
the audience in their underwear it's
like it's imagination that's the point
you're using it as a tool for yourself
it's kind of inward looking and I have
no problem with that kind of inward
looking stuff but if you started saying
no I am a funny comedian and someone
says I don't agree with you and you say
no you're wrong and I'm gonna teach your
kids that you're wrong and I'm gonna I'm
gonna Institute I'm gonna put myself in
Parliament because I think the
Parliament needs a bit more humor in it
and so one might even agree they might
say yea be great to have some comedians
in Parliament but but not you and then
you say no no you've got a choice about
this then people might start saying
actually
this is going beyond just a tool and
you're gonna have to actually be a lot
more justified anymore in your claims
that you are quite funny I mean that the
Church of England has 26 seats in our
upper parliamentary house reserved for
its bishops right well the only other
country I can think of that does that is
the Islamic Republic of Iran right it's
absurd how oh and one other area where
would we allow that that's right like if
if we have 26 seats in the House of
Lords reserved for white people and
someone said that's absurd and races and
then one said oh I know but like it's
probably quite useful for like British
nationalism if you know what are you
talking about this is absurd like as
soon as you start putting this into our
politics not just our politics but our
political institutions you can have to
have a lot more justification for that
but no problem with people doing it for
themselves you know what will you
believe in in private where you believe
in and what helps you get through the
day gets you out of bed in the morning
that's no business of mine but if you
start trying to teach it to my children
if you start trying to get schools
funded by the government that
proselytize this nonsense then I'm gonna
call it what it is I mean which is
absolutely I just like to say 26 white
people in the House of Lords
so Alex what would your counter-argument
be to the fact that many people see
atheism is a religion and that you have
you know absolutists
you know and there are people who adhere
to it in almost militant fashion yeah so
imagine I don't know take take the sport
of golfing let's say you've got the
people who golf and then you've got the
people who don't play golf I don't play
golf I say that somebody was really
annoyed for some reason that people who
played golf
I said golf course just kind of opened
up and took over some of the land that
they used to walk through or something
they can't get it and they were really
really annoyed and so they make this
sport out of like you know throwing
bricks onto the onto the golf course or
something to try and disrupt the golf
anyway and someone comes along and says
all these bloody non golfers they're a
sport in their own regard you know
throwing bricks and stuff and I'm just
like no no I just I just don't play golf
it's just something and then I would
yours
you take take part of sport and I say no
no you don't you know Sally I literally
I just don't place go that that's it and
says what about these extremists who
were going around throwing bricks into
into into golf and trying to score
points for getting the whole night that
that's like those people may also be
people who don't play golf but you not
playing golf is not definitionally that
right and it's the same thing being an
atheist it's just not being religious
right the word literally just means it's
not it's not atheism
it's a theism is just the Greek the
Greek Theo's for God a just means
without right you're living without the
existence of the God and of course there
are people who hate religion and are
extremists in that regard and all of
those people are atheists but not all
atheists are those people right it's a
cool atheism a religion just completely
shows a misunderstanding of what people
mean when they use the term IIIi don't
know any of my friends or colleagues
atheist friends of colleagues who makes
a claim there is no God who actually
make any propositional claims about it
at all they just they are just
unconvinced to the claim that there is
God that's why can a snake rather than a
theist you well this is the same thing
right well they're not the same thing
but they can they can exist at the same
time so that means ya agnosticism is
similarly Greek but comes from the word
for knowledge
so with agnosticism we're talking about
what people know do you know that
there's a God well of course no one
knows that makes us all technically
agnostic what we're interested in is
what we believe and that's where theism
comes into play you're either a theist
meaning you do believe the claim or
you're an atheist meaning you don't
doesn't mean you believe the opposite
claim but if you do believe the opposite
claim you are an atheist you know that's
a subset of atheism that's not what
atheism is right and people point to
people point to communist atheistic
regimes and things like this and say
that atheism is a religion and it's
caused harm and thinks it's like that's
definitionally just not what atheism is
hashtag not only do you not believe that
we have this because I'm an atheist but
I also believe that there's a part of us
that needs to believe in something so
you know if you know you see this you
know with horoscopes and you see this
way where it you know where we have this
sort of materialism where we buy and
consume in order to fill a void within
this
do not think that we need something if
we do then you should try finding it in
humanity it's them it's them it's the
most fulfilling like what do you think
is going to give you more purpose in
life your daily horoscope that tells you
well you know you know watch out for a
bad signal from a bird today or
something hmm or from the love of your
friends and family I get do people
really think you're assuming a lot about
his family though it's really important
to think about this like why is it when
people say but without religion I mean
you need something like it like a
horoscope why is that the first thing
that comes to mind it was a horoscope
and compared to that the latter than the
multitude of other things available to
us like I've never understood when
people when people say things like they
say like you know but surely you believe
in something mmm what does that even
mean like yeah I believe in the
existence of an external world you know
I I believe that I'm wearing a blue
jacket right now there you mean believe
in something you mean you believe in
something that the provides transcend
transcendent purpose do you mean you
believe in something that provides just
any kind of purpose oh you mean you
believe in something that has
explanatory power about how we got here
or explanatory power about why we got
here like just to say you must believe
in something is it such a is such a
broad thing to say it's like well
everyone believes in something short but
that's like almost trivially true so I
was like I don't understand what you
mean by that
thanks for destroying that argument
exhibit Francis gets destroyed every
episode you've just had your moment for
this one
[Music]
well let's move on and talk about animal
rights because this is something you've
been I think it's fair to say fairly
outspoken about what's your position on
veganism and animal rights I think that
the refusal to exploit sentient
creatures for non necessary purposes is
not just morally virtuous but a moral
obligation should be a baseline of our
ethical conduct not an extension of it
so don't eat meat don't exploit animals
don't exploit animals you know don't eat
them don't eat their products don't wear
them don't use them for entertainment in
sport entertainment I was trying to
think of the last time I used an animal
for entertainment that was Russia before
the Internet Alex looks horrified Oh
believe me the thing that happened in
factory farms are far more horrified
yeah of course okay that's actually
that's actually the interesting that's
one of the first interesting points that
people the people will will raise their
eyebrows that they don't man and this is
something that I realized myself back
when I used to eat meat
someone once made this point to me they
said it's a bestiality it's it's pretty
pretty disgusting and wrong right looks
like well I mean instinctively I want to
say yes and they say this but but if you
have sex with an animal there's at least
a chance that they might enjoy it
probably having a good time or at least
it's a pleasurable experience to
conversation is taking a turn but anyway
I'd love you to do that as a routine at
a local comedy club - I'd be [ __ ]
brilliant but but like I missed a thing
right the eyebrows go to the back a head
and then you say but but think about
this right like when it comes to like
slaughtering and killing an animal
that's obviously not in their best
interest probably not enjoying that kind
of thing so it's like it was an argument
from kind of saying like if we're
allowed to literally take a take a cow
put a bolt through its brain turn it
upside down slit its throat and watch it
bleed out but then that's that's just
fine and no one cares but as soon as you
put your penis in it all there that's a
that's a big ruckus like and I was like
that's that's a really good point now
luckily I'm able to go the one way of
saying neither of those things should be
done but I think as a meat-eater these
are these are the kind of these are the
kind of services that you have to start
considering like what else can that kind
of justification allow you to do the
kind of justifications that we produce
we desperately kind of clam before we're
trying to continue eating our burgers
and our milk and our eggs those
justification is you want to be careful
with them because they can lead you to a
whole host of really unfruitful places
so how many meet three days a week do
reckon you can have if you want to have
sex for the cow once a week so you're a
vegan put forward the case as to why we
should be vegan so there are a few ways
to go about it the first thing to note
is that usually I make a case from
consistency right I don't I don't work
from the ground up I take things that I
think other people already believe and I
try to just extend the logic so let's
start with something something we do
agree agree upon like I am presumably
speaking we're not racists gotta be
careful these days yeah I was think
about why right now it's weird because
we're kind of proving a negative here
it's like it's not the argument
shouldn't be why are you not the races
should be why should I be a racist and
that argument is flawed but I still
think about it you know reflect on this
right well let's take sexism as well
kind of keep them all in mind are men
and women the same are white people and
black people the same right that there
are differences between people people
have different height averages they have
different skin colors they have
different hair lengths and things like
this right but to be anti-racist or to
be anti sexist isn't to deny that
differences exists it's to say it's like
who cares about the different those
differences aren't morally relevant
right so let's think about the
differences between an animal and a peer
let's say for instance so one difference
is that a pig has more legs than we do
right is that what justifies the
difference in treatment of course it's
only that obviously that's morally
irrelevant right so the question becomes
what is the morally relevant difference
what is the difference between a pig and
a human the difference between them that
justifies the idea that if we even even
hurt one without their consent we can be
thrown to jail but the other one we can
do literally whatever we please to
what's the moral difference here and not
only do you need to find that difference
but it needs to be such to be consistent
here we need to find the difference that
if that difference were also true of the
human we
be ok we're doing it to the human so if
we say like the pig is different in this
respect it lacks this quality if that's
really the quality that justifies the
difference in treatment then we'd have
to say that if the human being also
lacked that quality we'd be okay with
slaughtering them so the question is
what's that quality because it's not me
who has to do the justifying here right
if you're causing suffering you should
justify that behavior right every time
we cause any kind of suffering we
justify it and a lot of the time we can
do so we justify Wars because we think
that they serve a greater end or
justification do we have for torturing
and killing innocent beings I guess the
argument there would be and I'm not
suggesting by the way that human beings
are carnivores by the process of
evolution but carnivores eat other
animals right so but Tigers don't eat
Tigers right it's not because they have
a moral hierarchy of some kinds it's
just they they don't eat other
carnivores right so from a leaveleave
shinnou perspective my understanding is
that we are we're kind of like 99% vegan
I suppose in terms of our evolution
that's kind of how we evolved but there
would you know if you look at Apes or
monkeys what they'll do is they mostly
through vegetables whatever
mostly through of course but and roots
and stuff like that but every now and
again they'll catch or whatever and eat
it yeah right so the argument to what
you're saying would be that we evolved
for a small part of our diet at least to
hunt and eat animals just like almost
every other animal is either prey or
predator in animal kingdom right so
there are two potential arguments at
hand want us to say that this occurs in
nature how can we be held morally
responsible we don't hold the line
morally responsible feeding the gazelle
yeah and the other argument is to say
that actually we do need some kind of
meat because it's part of our
evolutionary heritage which means that
we actually have a requirement right so
on the second point first it's it's
demonstrably not true right the only
thing that gives us what we need from
the food that we eat are the nutrients
contained within them and we can prove
that all the nutrients you need to
survive and not only survive but be
healthy
can be
she've Don a vegan diet with with quite
considerable ease in fact especially
living in in London it's one of the
easiest things to do and again it's a
point about necessity Jeff is that
really true I might ask you know because
I don't know it's true a lot so the
first thing that people worry about is
protein protein is the least of your
concerns I mean it's it's very it's very
easy to get the right amount of protein
yeah on on a vegan diet the thing you
really want to watch out for are
micronutrients things like iron
deficiencies might be high among vegans
because you know people don't want to
eat their leafy greens but that's really
all you have to do you can take a
multivitamin tablet if there's
supplement if you want to you don't have
to but you you know it's something like
over 60% of the American adult
population do that anyway it's a fairly
common thing to do the only thing that
you can't really get from a vegan diet
is vitamin b12 it's the one thing that
people will always bring up because it's
like the one thing that that only comes
from animal products well first thing to
know it doesn't technically come from
animal products it comes from bacteria
and the soil which the animals eat we
used to get it either through drinking
water and we get traces from the dirt in
the rivers or because our food wasn't
perfectly clean and in the specks of
dirt but also the stuff that we get from
the animal products today those animals
are being fed b12 supplements and then
we're then eating the animal so people
want to say that it's they don't want to
take a supplement because it's an
unnatural thing to do well everything
about factory farming is unnatural
including the fact that they're being
fed fed the supplements but it is
absolutely true that every single
nutrient you need can be achieved on a
vegan diet okay and let's come let's
come back to the line and gazelle yeah
well Lions also rape each other right if
you want to cause problematic if you
want to base your ethical conduct on the
conduct of lions then you go ahead but
you're not gonna have a very good time I
mean Lions Lions will often find a new
pride and male lions and they will kill
the younglings kill the male and rape
the female to repopulate the area with
their younglings now imagine somebody
trying to justify being a rapist by
saying we don't judge the lion for doing
it you'd laugh them out of the room it's
like of course we don't because we don't
base our ethical conduct on the conduct
of wild animals the difference that we
need to consider here is moral worth
versus moral agency right
moral agency is where you can be held
responsible for the actions that you
commit moral worth is weaker than that
it just means that you have as I say
like moral at the moral worth I mean it
is what it says on the tin so you could
take for instance a severely disabled
human child clearly or even just a
normal human child that's just just just
take someone who's young enough that
clearly they don't have a moral agency
right if they do something wrong we
don't really hold them responsible for
it because we recognize that they don't
have that agency but that doesn't mean
they don't have moral worth right if
somebody tried to hurt them they
wouldn't be justified in saying but the
baby just hit someone why can't I hit
the baby and say because there's a
difference right like you need to we
need to act in the ways and we need to
act in accordance with with what our
kind of natural position prescribes
right like we we have a capability for
rational thought in fact the very thing
the people often use to justify the
slaughter of animals it's the thing that
should justify the opposite they say
like but we're on another level to these
animals you know we're better than them
we're we're we're higher than them and
it's like if that's the case then we're
better than they are in terms of their
violence towards each other we're better
than they are in the terms of the idea
that they have to kill each other for
food like we're better because we're
moral creatures we're better because we
have a conscience we're better because
we're able to rise above that kind of
naturalistic carnivorous but hold on
with it
look a lion isn't gonna survive on a
vegan diet its digestive system its
whole body its yeah everything about the
lion is I don't want to use the word
designed but has evolved to make it a
carnival a lion can not survive without
eating other animals absolutely the
again yeah I hear you but my point is
that the lion Lions could very
comfortably I imagine survive without
raping each other maybe not as
successfully as they do but eating meat
for a lion is a natural part an
essential part of its evolutionary
background right so I don't think you
could judge a lion for eating meat right
so the argument would be that human
beings evolved to some extent to behave
in that way as well so judging us
for doing that is kind of I there's
something there's a weak link somewhere
Nagano maybe I haven't identified a
problem but I'm glad you changed the
word you change to saying it's essential
the line you changed saying it's natural
so we're saying it's essential yeah
that's exactly the point
right it's necessary for them to do so
they're obligate carnivores right they
don't have a choice in the matter we do
have a choice but we don't have to eat
me if we have to eat me then that's
another matter what we have here is a
situation where as as as we we've all
accepted at this point we don't have to
do it and when you accept that it means
that what you're doing is by definition
unnecessary and what the next stage of
the argument is that well what we're
doing cause is suffering so what we're
doing is causing unnecessary suffering
right and I think that the the baseline
of ethical conduct is to try to
eliminate unnecessary suffering right
it's as simple as that
I mean why don't we apply the same
arguments to dogfighting people who
breed dogs I mean it but people
generally have agreed that that's an
evil thing to do you know they're not
gonna get their money to that why why
why are people outraged when when there
are festivals in China where people eat
dogs
why there protests on the street of
London when that happens because we're
completely selective with our empathy
it's not like we don't care about
animals already all right these
arguments that we make about what's
natural and and what we should be
allowed to do to other animals because
of our evolutionary heritage it's like
if you want to use those arguments let's
apply them consistent consistently and
see how okay you are with dogs being put
into battery cages right we have animal
cruelty laws because we've recognized
that animals do have some kind of moral
worth and if they have any kind of moral
worth even the most minimal sense of
moral worth then what we do to them the
factory farms is in no way justified
right and certainly not by saying that
well you know for a lion it's necessary
to kill other beings in order to eat and
so for us even though it's not necessary
it's kind of maybe a little bit
necessary but not really so maybe we
should you know just take a pig into a
torture chamber so like I don't see the
I don't I don't follow the argument
right what do you want no I wanted to
touch on factory farming yeah because
it's this is something that's been
brought up
again and again and again and I think
people the average person who would be
exposed to this solve understands that
factory farming is not a good thing
but we're all busy people we don't
really have time to explore these
particular subjects could you just tell
the listener or the viewer why you
believe that factory farming is wrong on
their concentration camps for animals
right the the level of suffering going
on in these farms is so unimaginably
huge that's I think that's the real
reason people don't know what's going on
not because they don't have the time for
it everybody would have the time for it
if they had the slightest inkling of
what was going on there are I mean it's
different it's a different experience
for different animals right so so for
instance with with eggs to take one
example it's not the same chicken that
gives us meat that gives us X there are
rollers and layers and the layer they're
genetically engineered differently right
so then wants to lay eggs obviously only
the females lay eggs so when the males
are born they're totally useless right
and so I ask you what do you think they
do with them and they say well I guess
they're sold for me and I say no no this
is a different type of chicken and I
said what do you think they do with them
and they say I guess you I guess they'd
kill them it's like yeah how do you
think they do it I don't know they gas
them or something I'll chop off their
head they put them on a conveyor belt
and throw them into a blender just
chicks just a life simply because of the
fact that they're male millions and
millions and millions of them on end
just so that we can eat eggs right baby
chicks just been ground up alive right
the the treatment of pigs and cows is
obscene to get milk cows are forcibly
impregnated and then they give birth to
a calf I mean they produce milk for the
same reason we do is for their children
but the children obviously that have to
be taken away and that causes the same
kind of psychological distress that it
doesn't a human being again what for so
that we can have a glass of milk and
then what happens to that cow well it's
it's continually impregnated and
continually has its children taken away
for years and years until it finally
can't do it anymore and then it's sold
for me and it's slaughtered it's like
what like who doesn't who doesn't know
that this is the kind of stuff that's
happening who doesn't know that in order
to have milk a cow has to be pregnant
it's the same thing with the human being
and who doesn't know that if that milk
is meant for the charr
and the shelf has to be taken away and
who doesn't know that that child is
probably has a vault put through its
head or as sold for sold for me like who
really doesn't know that this is
happening and who thinks that it's
justified the I mean just just think
about what's going on here right
unimaginable levels of suffering
millions and millions of animals killed
every single hour just because we think
they taste nice there's a hell of a
justification what other what other kind
of immoralities are we going to allow
people to justify because of their
sensory pleasures hmm I wanted to talk
to you about the practical side of this
because the reality is the novel by
majority of people leave me I and while
you I think at the point you just made
it it is very strong I don't think we're
gonna convince people to not eat meat
based just on that because if that was
possible it would have happened by now
John I'm saying so first of all actually
just on the factory farming I mean would
you be a lot more comfortable with
people eating me if it was all grown
kind of like free-range grass-fed all
this kind of stuff yeah so the first
thing to note is that labels like free
Ranger generally mythical the
requirements for something to actually
be free ranges is people have this idea
of like you know happy chickens and
happy eggs and stuff like it's it's just
not true
you know these animals don't have to be
happy to produce the the food that we
eat from them chickens on free-range
farms they'll have access to the
outdoors for half a year they you know
these are animals are still caged
they're still it's all bread they're
still getting osteoporosis because
they're lying too many eggs there it's
still all of these problems are going on
even if they took a free-range label on
it if anybody's interested you can you
can watch footage from these farms my
friend ed who works for anyone knows it
will count co-founded an organization
called search recently did an expose
into UK dairy farms the campaign is
called dismantle dairy just showing
people what's going on in these farms a
few years earlier he produced a
documentary called Land of Hope and
Glory showing what's happening on red
tractor approved farms on farms that
have these kind of labels that are spell
to kind of satiate customers into
thinking that it's an okay thing to do
but remember we're still talking about
we're still talking about life here but
we're still talking about animals being
exploited for their products and for
their me so that we can have something
that we think tastes nice also that we
can wear them and stuff like the levels
of justification are are totally
mismatched
right we're not we're not just saying
that we want to slaughter and kill and
exploit animals for some great noble
purpose right because we want to win a
war because we want to kind of use
horses as transportation to get us onto
the battlefield or something like we
might have used to be able to say right
and we're not just saying how we want to
slightly slightly inconvenient a cow so
that we can have our mild convenience of
taste right like it's it's completely
mismatched like it means a single meal a
single burger that that bit of milk that
you have in your tea means absolutely
nothing to us but it means absolutely
everything the animal that produced it
what you're going to ask ourselves if
we're justified in doing it I also
disagree with you in saying that like
we're not going to convince people to be
vegan based on this argument alone I
mean you say it would have happened
already it's like every moral argument
takes time right the difference with
this like how long as Peter Singer asks
how long do you think it would have
taken for black slaves to become
liberated if they couldn't have spoken
for themselves how long do you think it
would have taken for women to be
grounded equality if they couldn't fight
for their own rhymes right this is one
of the arguments I always make when I'm
defending freedom of speech that
actually it's very important for people
who are at less than some way to be able
to do it so I guess you're saying
animals don't really have freedoms yeah
that's the thing you recognize how how
important it is yes how important it is
to have the ability to speak for
yourself in order to actually achieve
anything in terms of justice well these
animals can't talk themselves like they
need someone to talk for them I mean
what they can't they can't talk in the
sense that they can scream and if you've
ever seen an animal on a factory farm
then you know what it's trying to say to
you you don't need to ask you don't need
a translator but they can't write essays
they can't write political diatribes
they can't argue they can't they can't
argue back to the person who says shut
up I like the way you taste so you're
gonna you're gonna suffer and die
alright there's no argument back to that
that they can produce it has to fall on
and of course it's going to take a long
time but you know you might have said
the same thing like in in the in the
1700s you know people people roughly
knew that slavery was a bad idea if you
read the you can read the the the
letters in the correspondence during the
time at the production of the United
States Constitution the founding fathers
having this this incredible noble and
totally unrealistic and utopian success
of creating this nation and they're
writing the Constitution they're all in
high spirits and then comes the question
of slavery and they're using you know
they're using metaphors and they're
using they're using euphemisms because
everybody kind of knows that it's the
elephant in the room they knew it was it
wrong again and so many mind of that
point said like yeah come on like yeah
obviously if it were gonna happen it
would have happened by now people are
gonna be convinced behind the moral
argument to abolish slavery is gonna be
after they have to be practical things
can I have to prove that there's an
economic benefit to abolishing slavery
problem is that there wasn't in fact it
was the complete opposite right so what
what happened is people had to say no
I'm sorry time and time is up here the
moral argument is strong enough and if
you're not willing to consider it if you
don't have the time then we'll make you
half the time we'll give you the time
we'll provide the time we'll put in the
work we'll do the the investigations
we'll do the research and we'll put it
to you in play in English and then it's
up to you to just decide whether you
want to be on the right side of history
or not and Alex what do you think about
those people who go ok so you've made
those good you know those arguments
about factory farming it's diabolical
it's awful however even farming
agricultural farming creates a huge
amount of damage to the local wildlife
to the ecosystem the use of pesticides
the use of fertilizers so actually the
reality is that all our impact on the
the on the on the ecosystem through our
farming is detrimental yeah so the thing
to know is people say for instance like
you know growing crops the kind of crops
that we need on a vegan diet growing soy
these things are really really bad for
the environment is absolutely true but
we're currently growing enough crops to
feed the world population three times
over and then we're feeding it to
livestock and then we're eating the
livestock right so we would still be
minimizing our impact on the planet by
going vegan we'd actually be using less
soy because 85% of the soy that we
currently grown
it's fed to livestock it's fed to cows
right so like I agree with you you know
like yeah we should be reducing the
amount of soy that we're growing we
should be reducing the amount of crops
and land that we're taking up but if you
want to do that like it is still going
to want to go vegan I'd also say that
the the animal agricultural industry is
that is is it's such a large contributor
to to global warming most people who are
going vegan these days are doing it for
environmental reasons which I resent
because I think that's a bad reason to
go vegan and leaves us with the concern
that they don't that they might switch
back again if the environmental crisis
is abated it's just like a nice thing to
have on the side for me right there is
the the art the moral argument is so
impenetrably strong that i don't think
it needs anything else so how great is
it that just by the way if you do this
you'll also be doing single best thing
you can do as an individual to save the
environment you'll also be doing wonders
for your health like these are nice
little add-ons but they definitely not
necessary to make the argument hmm I can
just see the comments under this video
three cooks discussing how best to be a
soy boy options called me a soy boy yeah
yeah so I've been there man
having said that saw was discussed we we
stood up Katie Hopkins once by mistake
we was a friend of mine I'm supposed to
be interviewing her and she she'd
emailed him but it had actually gone to
his junk folder so he was waiting at the
wrong place so she was sort of the
Oxford Union kind of waiting around for
us to show and we just we never did
whereas I just called the soy boy by her
which is very painful haven't admit
Katie Hopkins isn't always wrong but
there's one question that I wanted to
ask so you bring up the health issue
what why is it healthier to be vegan
well it's not it's not necessarily
healthier it's just that so it's that
there are health benefits for instance
for to not eating things like red meat
and you'll often find that when people
go vegan they start paying attention
more to their to their diet and you're
less at risk of going overweight you
find yourself paying more attention to
the nutrients and you because you need
to get the right nutrients to be healthy
you you start focusing on man you become
healthier like a vegan diet or a meat
that I like like there are there are
there are benefits to both health-wise
although I think it's recommended that
you eat absolutely no red meat
because it's a carcinogenic and a cause
of heart disease although you know it's
all a little bit kind of muddy right now
well no one really quite knows what we
do know for certain is that being a
vegan is healthy right that's what
that's one thing we do know we know that
you can also be healthy on a meat-eating
diet to say which is healthier like it's
a difficult argument to make you could
probably say that eating meat will give
you a more convenient way to live a
healthier lifestyle and you'll get more
muscle mass and things like this but my
argument is this if it is healthy I
don't care what's healthier I care about
if it's healthy then it's not necessary
to eat meat and then it's immoral to do
so right like if we found out that it
was if it was it was healthier for our
diets if we started eating the the flesh
of tortured babies human babies people
would be like well obviously we're not
going to do that and and I'd say what
are you denying that it's healthier it's
like a quotient in it like we can
recognize that something's healthier but
also recognize that that's not an
argument to do it
so if meat eating is healthier like okay
great I still think it's wrong still
think we shouldn't be doing it just as
if you take steroids in a sports
competition you will perform better that
is actually true but we're still not
going to allow you to do it and I know
listen we're almost out of time I wanted
to say by the way on the whole male
chick thing I just said like just a
bunch of males on the conveyor belt
being thrown into a blender that's like
a feminist wet dream but before we let
you go the last question we always like
to ask is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about the society the
will to be talking about beyond the
scope of maybe what we've covered
already yeah well I mean the annoyingly
that the thing that does bring to mind
is is animals yes is the treatment of
animals right it's like it they are they
are so not spoken about like the idea so
things like religion things like think
things like that they get mentioned in
in you know you know House of Commons
they get they get brought up in policies
there's like at least on the manifesto
animals are nowhere to be seen
right the idea that we should the idea
that we should be vegan is totally
radical right it's it's a totally
radical idea such that like if you found
that even mentioned in a party's
manifesto you think whoa that's crazy
but what are we talking about here
we're talking about boycotting an
industry that's torturing innocent
creatures but how is that become a
radical thing to do right the reason why
is because people aren't talking about
it people people it's not normalized
when you say that these things are going
on people say well I'm sure that I must
just be a bad apple you know that I
can't really be I mean it's really like
they're either be regulations in place
you know that kind of thing it's like no
there's there's absolutely not and the
reason we're not aware of that is
because we're just not talking about it
the moment that we do begin talking
about it as a society is the moment that
it will begin to end because there's no
way once you give it a moment's thought
and you realize what's actually going on
that you can continue to justify it the
only actual justification for the way
that we're treating these animals is
ignorance and that's a hell of a
justification and there's not one that
you're able to make for yourself because
the moment that you start making it
you're no longer ignorant so I think
that certainly that the it's obvious to
me and I think it will be obvious to
future societies that in the same way
that we look back on history and it's
full of white dudes and we think ah
where were the women it's like it's a
it's one of those things there's like
clearly you know people weren't people
just weren't like representing them they
just when talking about them it's like
we look back and it's quite obvious to
us now right I think you'll be equally
obvious in the future that people will
be like hold on these guys were like
losing their minds over potentially
exiting the European Union whilst in the
time it took between you know the vote
and today we've sorted what hundreds of
billions of land animals and trillions
of sea animals and future societies
we'll look back in the way that we look
back and say like so these guys were
like these guys were like arguing about
this political Union while they were
literally owning slaves these people
were arguing about these weirdly
specific issues what well people were on
slave ships how could they possibly have
that kind of cognitive dissonance I
think people will say the same thing
about us right now
how were they not talking about this how
is this not front-page news every single
day it's just because it's not in the
conversation well thanks very much for
coming on the show you have a brilliant
youtube channel how do people find you
online where do they go for that
everything is just cosmic skeptic it's
quite a
unusual name so /e cosmyk skeptical on
any side and you'll probably find me
there fantastic we'll go and check out
excited to some great work thanks very
much for tuning in to watch us this week
and we'll see you in a week time with
another brilliant episode take care see
you next week guys thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word